hello there you're watching the press
preview a first look at what's on the
front pages
as they arrive in the next half hour
we'll see what's making the headlines
with the daily mirror columnist susie
boniface and editor of the politico
london playbook
alex wickham so let's see what's on some
of those front pages
boris johnson is coming under pressure
to end the system of self-isolation
after being pinged by the nhs covet app
reports the telegraph with ministers
urging the prime minister to ditch the
requirement for fully vaccinated people
the metro also leads with boris johnson
and the chancellor having to
self-isolate on so-called
freedom day saying that you turned on
taking daily tests
to avoid quarantining after a backlash
brush johnson's spending freedom day at
checkers after changing plans to skip
quarantine that's the lead on the
express
that's also on the front of the
financial times along with retailers and
producers warning about staff shortages
and price increases
because the number of workers isolating
is putting pressure
on the supply chain pm and sonar
isolating on freedom day after trying to
dodge the rules that's the headline in
the eye
and the mirror goes with boris johnson
asking people in england to be cautious
while
plowing on with his scrapping of all
virus restrictions
the lifting of coronavirus rules is the
yorkshire posts to lead as well
the guardian however goes with a
completely different story leading on a
special investigation
the star has boris johnson's u-turn on
quarantining on its
front page
and the mail goes with business leaders
warning about the pandemic
two and also changes to self-isolation
rules for frontline nhs and social care
staff
to help avoid staff shortages so
reports of a change in the
self-isolation rules
for nhs staff let's bring in our deputy
political editor sam coats for more on
that sam what do we know
we can confirm that from monday morning
nhs staff and social care staff who come
into contact with somebody
who tests positive for coronavirus and
who's contacted by nhs tests and trace
all pinged by the app
will no longer have to self-isolate for
10 days
sanja javid says that we're fortifying
our collective
security in england at least it's an
important moment
not just for nhs and social care workers
but also it's the first big moment that
the government appear to be conceding
that the scale of the number of people
that are testing positive over 40 000
today and the numbers who are
self-isolating as a consequence of
coming into contact with people
who test positive which could reach 1.4
million a week if we reach a hundred
thousand cases a day
as sergey javid predicted he's having an
impact on essential
infrastructure but the problem for the
government is that the nhs and society
aren't the only two bits of essential
infrastructure
in this country also transport you've
already got trains being cancelled
because there aren't enough drivers
or maintenance or utilities all of these
things
business groups begging for the
self-isolation rules
uh to be watered down today tony blair
has called for the nhs
test and trace quarantine requirement to
be scrapped so often in this pandemic he
has actually been a trendsetter and
ministers have followed
his advice but there is concern in
westminster
that the test and trace the nhs
isolation requirement 10 days at home is
actually
welcomed by some scientists as a kind of
backdoor lockdown to keep more people
from coming into contact with others
they want this to stay because they're
worried about the speed
of the increase in case rate so they
think there shouldn't be changes and
they're fighting against them which is
why test and release
for most people hasn't happened once
again another difficult dilemma for
boris johnson
sam thank you all right well let's bring
in suzy boniface and alex wickham
now to take a closer look at the papers
um
susie and alex thanks so much for
joining us good evening to you
i suppose we should start with a
reflection on the day there was
this u-turn but the key to this one i
suppose was the timing and the
eye highlights that 8 am
uh johnson and chancellor say they're
exempt from self-isolating 10
38 am furious backlash forces
the u-turn alex what did you make of the
day
oh yeah well there really is only one
story in town today and this is the
extraordinary two hours and 38 minutes
this morning
um after downing street surprised i
think uh
most uh journalists certainly uh and uh
probably the general public as well this
morning at eight o'clock by telling us
that uh boris johnson and rishi sunak
had been pinged but they
were not going to isolate which is
obviously
um you know went down extremely badly
it somehow along last night when this
decision was made
no one in number 10 appears to have sort
of quite grasped the absolute outpouring
of
uh fury basically on twitter but not
just on twitter i was having
you know whatsapps from non-political
friends and you know
normal people who it immediately cut
through to
and you know it very very quickly became
very obvious to number 10 that this was
a
barnard castle style level disaster
on for them if they didn't very swiftly
u-turn
which they pretty quickly did but i
think to be honest the damage is done
and you know there are you could imagine
huge numbers of very frustrated people
1.7 million people currently isolating
and they will be thinking well this lot
tried to get away without doing it
they're the ones setting the rules why
on earth is it one rule for them and
another for us
um susie what did you make of it were
you more surprised
with the initial news that they were
exempt from self-isolating or 160
minutes later
the u-turn i was surprised that it took
160 minutes for them to u-turn because i
mean
this government has basically u-turned
solidly for you know a year and a half
now
we don't have u-turns so much as you
know just a rubber ring on the road
halfway down the m1 where
boris johnson's just doing doughnuts in
his policy car
um so it's not surprising he's had to do
the opposite of what he said
it's not surprising that he's come out
with a video today claiming that he only
briefly thought about maybe joining this
trial
the whole point about a medical trial is
you don't get to choose what side you're
on a friend of mine another mirror
columnist roswell jones has had to
isolate
with her family she has been asked to
take part of the trial she was randomly
selected
and of course she's ended up in the
control group so she's having to isolate
anyway without doing
the daily tests to release which is what
boris johnson was
not hoping for but was guaranteeing
where he got to go on this trial which
only about 40
000 brits are on anyway and there are
half a
million people self-isolating in the uk
more than half a million that figure is
going to triple in the next couple of
weeks
um and already just with half a million
people are self-isolating
we have hospitals factories retailers
haulers tube lines
trains buses the isle of wight ferry
restaurants theaters
closing down threatened with closure
disrupting their services
not able to reopen in the way that so
many people want them to
um all because of the way this one man
has handled the pandemic so far and the
reason that he's insisting on this
freedom day
is to mark his freedom from restrictions
so he can
say i've let you all out ra i'm
brilliant it was some great piece in the
paper yesterday talking about how he
wanted to have a churchill moment
with some stirring rhetoric in a you
know historic location that's
historically
linked to churchill wanted to say i've
given you back your freedom britain the
pandemic you know we've beaten it
and you know chris and the nhs is being
even just as good as the few
or something the whole thing's
completely inappropriate the pandemic's
still raging
probably going to for five to ten years
in different parts of the world
and it really needs a grown-up to be
running the country but from what
dominic cummings has said about him
downing street's probably quite glad
he's not there getting in the way
alex it was interesting um wasn't it
that in that video
he did say we did look briefly at us
taking part in the pilot scheme i mean
how brief was it if you've got
generic out doing the media rounds this
morning defending it
yeah i mean i don't think that that many
people
who have sympathy for for robert
generick but uh
you definitely did this morning watching
him uh have to go out and back for
for this government line that actually
it was perfectly understandable that uh
the
two of the two most powerful people in
the country didn't have to follow the
rules that everyone else had followed
and
you know i imagine he would be slightly
miffed to see the
second statement come through just as he
finished his broadcast round this
morning
but yeah i mean you have a situation
tomorrow freedom day the day all the
restrictions lift
but cases are at 50 000 a day at least
and going up
the prime minister the chancellor the
health secretary are all locked in at
home
to isolating pinged one with covers
himself
i mean it's not an ideal situation for
the government is that this is not when
boris johnson
embarked on this irreversible road map
all those months ago
i don't imagine this is how he thought
uh the freedom day into step four would
be going
um just in reference to what sam coats
was telling us now
um susie do you think the front of the
daily mail they've referenced this as
well
saying that key nhs workers will be
exempted from the quarantine rule
to help avoid hospitals cancelling
operations because of staff shortages
i mean do you think this is the
beginning of the end of the
ping demk as it's been called or ping
mageddon as i've read somewhere else
i love the way um some parts of the
press are blaming this on a phone app
and it's too sensitive uh and it's it's
just mad it's technology gone mad
the the fact that people are getting
pinged in you know
50 more people self-isolating this week
than last week
is because infections are shooting
through the roof
and they're shooting through the roof
because we've been easing restrictions
apparently slowly and cautiously but in
just such a way that over the summer
peak it was always going to cause a
massive wave
uh and what i'm just saying there about
this is just what you know boris johnson
would not have wanted when he launched
freedom day kind of thing in the plan
and the road map
this is what scientists have been
warning about for
months they said last winter we would
have next winter was probably going to
be spent in a lockdown and we'd be
facing problems with flu as well and
anyone could see
that although we have weakened the link
between uh the
virus and death and hospitalization the
link is still there there are 550 people
on mechanical ventilation today in
british hospitals
having to have a machine breathe for
them within 28 days days of
of a positive covert test they are
younger they are healthier they are
people who have
had some jabs or if not all of their
jabs
boris johnson's video there he sounds
quite raspy he sounds like he's got a
bit of a
a bit of a cold at least and hopefully
it doesn't get any worse for him but
he has known this he has had the
briefings before we did
all right and i've known this was coming
for months so if an idiot like me is
figuring it out how come the prime
minister hasn't what's wrong with a man
what's he doing all day
hello again to you both let's kick off
with um children and vaccines because
this obviously is
a global conversation um the daily
telegraph
saying that the jcvi is expected to
announce today that only
vulnerable children susie are going to
get the jab
yep uh and other countries are
vaccinating uh
all children over the age of 12. in here
they're talking about only vulnerable
children over the age of 12 people who
are about to turn 18.
um and neil ferguson uh one of the stage
scientists whose modelling has been
influential in this pandemic has said
that basically if you don't vaccinate
children and teenagers in particular
you're never going to reach
herd immunity now if we want to try and
uh
see things from the prime minister's
point of view for a moment if we can
um the idea of there being rampant
infections during the summer holiday
would imply that you can let younger
people
children who are less likely to be
affected by covid
get infected steadily and they would
achieve that herd immunity without
vaccination
perhaps that's the plan perhaps it will
even work i don't know
but in the meantime what we've got uh is
this pindemic
where uh the government phone app which
we've all been urged to
download and abide by even though it's
advisory um
says that you know even if you have a
child who's got an infection your whole
family has to
survive isolate for a while which means
parents don't work which means trains
don't run which means lorries don't
deliver food
shops don't open so on and so forth just
what we're starting to see here in the
next few weeks now and over the summer
holiday i think
is the up flip side to what we've heard
for the past year
everything we've heard about how
damaging lockdowns are and how damaging
the government responses to covid
is now going to be shown the reverse
side of that which is how damaging it is
not to have restrictions and what kind
of effect that can have
so we'll learn won't we whether or not
we can trust the prime minister
um alex let's leave covert behind we've
spoken about global all day um and let's
stay with the telegraph but look at what
um the
the only african tutor at oriole college
has been saying about
um cecil rhodes and inequality
yes this is the story that the oriole
college's only african tutor says that
oxford on should stop throwing tantrums
over cecil rose and this is a bit of a
striking intervention on this debate
that this sort of
culture war debate that has raged for
the last well the last year or two now
really hasn't it
about pulling down statues but it's
basically of sort of historical
bad guys many people would see sort of
imperialists uh
people from the past who've done various
terrible things but are nonetheless
historical figures
and i think this is an argument that the
government would quite like to have this
week and this is the sort of thing where
you know that they they would be praying
for us to not be talking about cavid and
not to be talking about
the things that we are going to talk
about over the next few days and
but it is it is interesting to see that
you know once again
on this on this sort of uh this sort of
statute row
this this is the one bit of the culture
war where the government feels that it
is on very
solid ground they think that the idea of
pulling down statues is is not at all
uh popular among among the general
public no matter what the the historical
figure may have done
um there where are there other things
like taking the knee
as we saw with the england team the
government feels a lot more the tourists
feel a lot more on difficulty
we've got a minute we've got a minute
quickly just just have your say
people that were alive at the time i
don't know about alex average very young
compared to me
but um i mean people remember saddam
hussein's statue coming down remember
the statues of joe stalin coming down
and the statues of chaucesky coming down
people are fine with statues coming down
when their statues are horrible people
genuinely